おれのスマホどこいった？
あれスマホ、スマホ〜
あ、あったあったあった。
オッケーイ
わあ～！！
ぱ～～～～～～っ！
あー、とんでいっちゃった…
みなさん”牛乳”、知ってますでしょうか
まあ知らないー、人はいないと思うんだけども
まあまあ、、これですわ
もう牛乳飲めっつったら僕はいつもこれを飲んでいます。
おいしい牛乳
ま、簡単に言えば
オウシ、オウシさんのお乳からとれる
お乳です。
お乳としか言いようがないよ
凄いことを見つけたんですよ
牛乳を、100回…
100回振った牛乳は何もしていない牛乳に比べて
甘みと旨みの値が高くなる傾向があるという
調査結果が出ているみたいです
ホントかどうか知らないよ？
ホントかどうか知らないんですけども
そういう結果が出てるんで
牛乳が真っ白なのは脂肪やたんぱく質の分子が小さな集団を作り
「コロイド」という状態で溶液にあるためらしいです
コロイドっていうものが均一に広がってると牛乳ってのはおいしくなると
この紙パックの中の牛乳も、コロイドは
均一な状態で入れられているらしいです。
が！
しかし、脂肪の分子は脂肪の分子同士
たんぱく質の分子はたんぱく質の分子同士で集まりやすくなるみたい
そういう性質があるために
冷蔵庫に静かにおいている間に
コロイドの分布に偏りが出てきちゃう
ま、最初は均一に入ってたコロイドなんだけども
置いてくうちにね、そのなんか徐々に均一じゃなくなってくるらしいです。
なるほどな
ということは、この中のコロイドは今
均一じゃないわけだ
均一じゃないんだけども、これを振って飲むと
おいしくなるらしいです。
なるほどね
そうなんだ
マジか～、普通に驚きだわ
味が微妙にホントに違うらしいですよ
凄い微妙～な違いらしいんで
振った牛乳と振ってない牛乳の味のおいしさが分かる人は
味の違いが判る素晴らしい人になるみたいです。
俺の出番だ！
はっ！そう！この俺以外に味の違いが
判る男なんて
いないだろ？
今日の動画では、振った牛乳と振ってない牛乳の味の違いを俺が当てるだけの
超単純明快、天才的な動画です。
今振ってないからさ、その、偏ってる状態でしょ？
美味しくないほう…美味しくないほうをこっちにします。
あんまり動かさないように入れるね
コロイドが偏った牛乳が
こっちのペットボトルに注がれています。
おけ！
振ると美味しくなるんだよね？100回振るのか…
ううぉうぉうぉうぉうぉうぉうぉ！！！
うヴぉお゛おへ！(嘔吐)
えっへ、ちょっと待って
何回振ったっけ？
はぁ～ふぅ～、はぁ～ふぅ～
うヴぉヴぉヴぉ！！！
や、こんだけ振ったんだから味の違いはあるでしょうや！
わ、もう泡じゃん！！
待って、泡になってるよ！！
これ美味いのか？
泡じゃん！もう
よ～し、よしよし
ああ゛ぁぁぁあ！
やべ、溢れちゃう！
溢れちゃう！
不味いので×(バツ)
こっちが美味いので○(マル)
こっちが不味い牛乳、こっちが美味しい牛乳です
今から目隠しして当てるんですけども
その前にちょっと一回味の違いだけをちょっとー
感じさせてく
まずは不味い方から！
うんうん
おいしい牛乳
やっぱこっちの方がどれぐらい美味しいかってのを知りたいっすね
ここでも振って、美味しくしときます
いただきます！
え、待って！
俺分かるよ！！
分かる、分かる、分かる！！
分かる！味の違いが
いやでもなんかね、その、泡の感じでー、『あ、泡だな』って思っちゃうんで
グイッと飲みます。
グイッと飲めば分からないと思うんで
見ててくだせぇ、皆の衆！
俺の！味覚センサーの力を
もう一回ちゃんと振りますー
おっけ！
じゃあこれをシャッフルします
(早送り中、何か言ってる)
はい！
では、美味しい方を当てましょう。
まずはこっちから！
いや、も、もーぉまえらビビんなよ
俺、ホントに、いけるから
グイッといきます！
うーん
こっち
グイッといきます！
ぉぁ！
お～、これさぁ！
こっちが美味しいです！
こっちが100回振った方！
同じじゃねぇか。
ちょっと俺には分からなかったな～
けど何かホントに何か、科学的に違うみたいなので～
もしよかったら皆さんやってみてください
僕は～
味オンチです！！